[Music]
you
good morning friends so in today's
course what we are going to do is we are
going to take a new topic on cognitive
psychology which is called problem
solving and so problem solving is like
the culmination point of any cognitive
process now when I say this problem
solving is the culminating point of any
cognitive process what do I mean by that
now it's that process which comes right
after something is encode something is
perceived something is being attended to
and then a problem is generated look at
any problem in this world look at the
problem perception or looking at a tree
or looking at a visual world around you
now the process starts by looking at the
distal stimulus then forming the
proximal stimulus then forming a percept
out of it which is the process of
perception this percept is then
basically given attention which is the
process of attention a sustained
attention and through its certain
characteristics of the perceptor
processed after that next process comes
in is basically called storing this
material that you are storing this
visual information which is in terms of
mental representation of the visual
nature making or storing this
representation into short first in the
short-term memory and then storing it to
long-term memory now once that gets
stored into long-term memory it is then
analyzed and the analysis of this
percept for generating meaning is
basically problem-solving basically what
you have seen or as we as I describe
this process the in the Mentalist
presentation of what you saw as a distal
stimulus the meaning part of it the
analysis part of it is called problem
solving and so looking at something in
the environment
is the start of the cognitive process
and the point at which you need to
decide or before deciding the point at
which you you ask this question of what
is it that I am looking at is called
problem solving and so basically what is
the problem here the problem here is
what are you looking at now
problems are everywhere if you look
around anything that you do any
cognitive process raises a problem and
so it's the next to last step in
problem-solving that is by the three
sections of problem solving decision
making and reasoning are called the
higher cognitive functions why are they
called the higher cognitive functions
because these processes actually make
you do the interpretation of the stimuli
up till now whatever we have looked at
in terms of perception memory attention
and categorization and language all
these processes were required to take in
information from the environment and
then encode it or form mental
representations of it the process of
problem-solving a process of
decision-making in the process of
reasoning are the three processes which
actually help us in making
interpretations of things making
interpretations of what the visual
stimulus is or what whatever problem is
being put on to the cognitive system so
then let's look at the first slide which
I have over here and so these presents
some basic problems in life and so what
you see here are natural problems and
I'll also explain to you a natural
problem of how what a problem is in a
few minutes so in the first slide as you
see the fish has a problem of having a
problem with the fish food which is
outside its box and so the product the
problem solving technique that it is
using is basically to receive that it
needs food represents this mental
representation in the food is realizes
the food is outside the place in which
the fish is the aquarium in which the
fish is and so decides to use this time
anger to get the food similarly there
are other funny problems like example
the one you see in the right extreme
right top is the idea of solving a
problem and so we generally use this
idea of thinking outside this box and so
this person has now come out of the box
as the literal the metaphorical box that
I'm talking about and so he has come out
of the room from where the problem is
you know he doesn't know how to get in
and so that is the problem for him I so
he thought that he should think outside
the box and so he came out of it and the
last one and are the bottom slides you
see this cat having this problem of food
which is in in in this particular box
and so what the cat decides is to use
this kind of a problem-solving technique
although the easiest technique would be
to hit this bottle and get it out but
the cat decides to go on into this so
basically through these funny pictures I
am we are demonstrating water problem
and so in your life also in your
experience of everyday day-to-day
experiences you have a lot of problems
and so one of these problems could be
taking an exam or it could be to do your
Academy co-op and so when one of the
things that happens in the Caddy mix is
is writing a paper or writing a
dissertation and so that could be also a
problem so this kind of a thing the
writing a dissertation requires certain
kind of input or certain kind of
processes which you should go through to
solve this problem and this idea of how
do we solve of writing a problem how do
we solve this problem of writing a
dissertation or basically a paper for
some course that is a that could be
considered as a problem and so solution
to this lies in identifying something
called the initial state which is the
state at which you identify that what is
the problem and defying something called
the goal state which is the state or
which is the point at which you have
written the paper and certain rules and
certain hindrances to it so certain
rules of what you should do in what you
should not do and basically our
hindrances in terms of what can be done
or what are the problems in your face so
taking the idea of a problem of writing
a paper for your carrying
course this problem has an initial state
where you are worrying about writing
this paper we are thinking about writing
this paper and this is the initial state
the goal state is that state where you
have finished your paper and you're
happy or you have got a B or C or
whatever into that paper maybe an a I
don't know
depending on your intellect you would
get any numb any letter grades out of it
so that's the goal state where you are
finally successfully it in the paper and
then there are certain rules the rules
are that you have to follow certain
sections certain certain kind of
knowledge and or certain kind of strict
adherence to for example you cannot copy
things from the internet you have to
think about the genuine problem you
certain ways if it's arithmetic problems
you use certain kind of an arithmetic
rule or if it is a problem from
psychology use certain kind of knowledge
from psychology which suggests what can
happen in what cannot happen and then
basically certain kind of inferences
interesting is the term of the fact that
it may be you are hungry at this point
of time and so that is an inference or
the fact that you have to go with your
friends out today evening and say we do
not get time to write the paper so these
are the hindrances or innocence could be
a number of things and so basically then
this is how the problem really work so
this is how the demonstration of her
problem is so right so basically any
problem will have these four parts and
so let us discuss this in detail so what
is a problem then what do we call a
problem and as I said as I explained to
you with an example of what a problem is
generally a problem consists of several
basic elements one the first part of it
is called the initial state this is
situation and the beginning of a problem
so this is the state or this is the
point at which a problem starts right
this is the state value this is the
point do you realize that you have a
problem and this is the point when you
start creating mental representations of
the problem or encoding the problem as
such or realizing that there is a
problem or you have come to a point or
you have
in in your life or in your cognitive
process where something is creating
hindrance of something is creating
disturbances and so now you two need to
solve it so the first state is
realization that you have a disturbance
and this disturbance should be cleared
out and that is what the initial state
is matching the initial state is a state
which is called the goal state now this
is that state which you arrive after you
have solved a problem and so this is
that point which will come to you once
you have solved the problem once you
have acquired the solution to a problem
and then you become happy you become
elated or whatever you do and whatever
feeling you have once you solve the
problem that is called the goal state
and then there are two set certain sub
States for exact of rules and they said
constraints that must be followed so
certain rules for example this what can
be done and what cannot be done what is
allowed and what is not allowed to solve
the problem and a set of obstacles for
example hindrances that has to be
overcome so yeah as explained in the in
the paper writing problem the hunger
that you are feeling or the fact that
you have to go with your friends today
evening all these things are called
hindrances or set of obstacles which are
thought they so basically then a problem
definition of a problem has DNE problem
has these four points on to it
now obviously the question now comes in
that what are the type of problems how
many types of problem can exist and so
there are two basic categorizations
which are out there we will just look at
these two basic categorizations the
first categorization is the difference
between a well-defined and ill-defined
problem what is a well-defined problem a
well-defined problems are those problems
which are cleared and structured and
they have very clear and structured
initial state goal states and
constraints and all are understood for
it for example a problem of writing a
paper now when you are thinking of
writing a paper it's a very clear
problem you know that there is initial
state the worry that you are having the
final state where you want to reach and
you know all the hindrances which is out
there and so these are called very
defined problems so those problems which
present themselves in a very concise way
where you know where you start from and
where you want to go and you also are
able to see the set of rules which you
need to follow and the set of
that you need to that that you will face
in the way is called a well-defined
problem for example think of a problem
getting a license now when you want to
get a license there are said this the
initial state is you don't have a
license the final state is getting a
driving license and then there are
certain rules for example certain rules
have to be followed you have to give a
particular example our learning exam and
then after the learning test you have to
give the full test and in that year to
scroll the driving so you have to learn
and so on and so forth and certainly
Indian says the influences may be to
study for the exam to want to pass the
first learning test and then to pass the
second learning test to make enough
number of practices the fact that you
don't own a car and then you want to
learn car so basically then the fact
that you have to go to someone who has a
car and then get his permission so these
are the kind of hindrances which is out
there and so these are well-defined
route in addition to the well-defined
problems are ill-defined problems now
what are these problems these are fuzzy
and abstract problem that is the initial
goal state and constraints have gaps in
understanding leading to difficulty in
assessing the solution now in this case
what happens is there is a initial state
there is a final state but you don't
know how to go from the initial state
and the final state or then you don't
know how to what are the hindrances in
it for example let's say that tomorrow I
want to stand in an election and become
a minister now if this is the initial
state I don't know what the final state
would be of course becoming a minister
the final state but I don't know how the
process is what are the endurance is
what are the steps to be taken and how
do you become a minister or what is a
minister what kind of minister should I
become and all those questions are there
and then the kind of rules that I have
to follow so what are the rules of
nominations when they are there on what
basis is my nomination can be rejected
how to stand from someone how to impress
people to so that they vote for you
since it's a democracy so people vote
for you and so many other things are
there so I don't know on these in
Integra C's I don't know all these
hindrances which are going to be there
and all the rules which
out there and so this is an ill-defined
problem for example about a person like
me who's an academician to become a
minister there is a set up itself
becoming a minister itself is a really
defined problem or going to the moon is
an in defined problem I don't know how
to go to the boat right where should I
apply and what should I do to go to the
moon so this is an ill-defined problem
now in addition to well define an
ill-defined problem there is another
categorization out there which is in
terms of routine and non-routine problem
and that is routine problems are those
which you are familiar with the type of
process that you have to follow and non
routine problems are problems where you
don't know what steps to follow so
basically in terms of well-defined and
ill-defined you can also have a match
between routine and non-routine problems
so routine problem is one that can be
solved by applying well-practiced
procedures right for example writing
exam making tea so in making P you know
what to do so start with boiling the
water pour sugar into it to put milk
into it boil it for some time with tea
leaves and then you get a tea so this is
a well-defined problem where you know
number of steps that has to be there
the kind of hindrances that is their
initial state where you have water and
other materials other raw materials were
from which tea is made and a final state
where you finally get that liquid which
you call tea and enjoy and so this is a
routine problem opposed to this is
basically a non routine problem
something that you don't face every day
for example let's say you have an
accident and in this accident or you
have now got a twisted ankle now this is
not a everyday thing for you and so this
is a non routine problem so how do you
go ahead and treat this or how do you go
ahead and take precautions and so this
is a non routine problem because you
don't take this every day or the idea of
writing a research paper because that
doesn't happen every day you don't do it
or so on and so off and so often and so
that you are familiarity with this so
twisting an ankle treating a twisted
ankle or any other kind of problem which
is not well-defined which doesn't happen
too often for you and so you're not
familiar with the process is called a
protein problem so basically then to
categorizations one is in terms of
well-defined and ill-defined problem and
the other in terms of what is a routine
problem and non routine problem
so basically when this problems rezoned
there are certain ways to solve this
problem there are certain answers to
solving this problem but there are
certain challenges out there which
happens or which arise when you solve
problems there are certain challenges
which is out there for example problem
solving is the last hurdle to most
cognitive process that I have been
saying all along and it takes a long
time to accomplish up till now you have
seen those processes cognitive processes
which help you in to encode information
make mental representations realize that
some information is there store it and
then basically that's the end of it
right understand in which format is
appearing and it and store it in some
format and so on and so forth this is
the step problem solving is the step
where you realize what the problem is or
realize what is to be done with whatever
has been stored and what is to be
generated out of it right so that is the
problem-solving position and the solving
problem does take more time it takes
more time because you have to realize
what what where you are and where you
want to go right if you got if you have
a problem you know you should have know
where you want to go if you don't know
where you want to go then it is not a
problem-solving technique or this is not
problem solving so you always know where
you want to go or what is the goal state
in a problem so assessing problem
solving in terms of accuracy rate
provides a rather draws estimate of
problem solving proficiency so why am I
saying that that accuracy is not a good
idea accuracy does not demonstrate how
do you solve a problem now a person
could be very familiar with the problem
it could be a very routine problem and
so his accuracy would be very high but
then that doesn't guarantee the fact
that he the way he is solving a problem
how he is solving a problem or what is
the way in which is solving a problem
just with the fact that since he has
seen problems like this and so basically
he solves it much faster or more much
accurate doesn't give any sense of what
the problem is or how the
solving technique is so being accurate
is just a chance factor right and so
trans sector accuracy has nothing or
very less informative about the
problem-solving techniques the other way
to look into it is measuring solution
times which provides some useful
information but doesn't shed much light
on the result of processing now how
quickly you solve a problem again how
quickly you solve a problem says how can
you move from the initial state to the
goal State but it doesn't tell you
whether you realize the hindrances
whether you got through the real
illnesses maybe you are too lucky and
the fact that a number of hindrances
doesn't arise so you haven't considered
all the hindrances or you are you are
lucky to get a set of rules which
actually take you through the problem
space we'll come to the idea what a
problem spaces in in the later section
but maybe that is the reason how you
solve the problem
and so basically solution times are no
guarantee to how the processing or what
is the kind of processing which is
happening so neither accuracy nor
reaction time which are the two major
things in terms of behavioral research
remember lecture one on methods of doing
cognitive psychology and one of the
methods were the behavioral methods in
the behavioral methods we were looking
at something called speed accuracy
trade-off or Sweden accuracy as being
two major ways of solving problems in
cognitive psychology are dealing with
product cognitive psychology related
problems and so both accuracy in
reaction time doesn't give you too much
information about the solution process
of how does it happen
so basically then there are other ways
of also how problems under should happen
so these are the two ways of solving the
problem but it doesn't tell you how the
problem solution really happens and so
solution of problems of how people
actually went and solve a problem it's
really a difficult thing to assess and
so one of the ways to do - basically
whenever methods which I use to
basically come up with the solution was
called the idea of a verbal protocol but
even before we go there I have a problem
for you
and let's see how do you solve it so
this problem says that look at this
problem and I'll give you a minute to
actually read that and then basically
come up with an answer so leave this
problem and let's see if you can answer
it I will give you half a second to read
this problem maybe one second to read
this one minute to read this problem and
come up with an answer so starting now
here is your 30 second period for
reading the problem and coming up with
an answer
so the 30 second period is up and I'm
pretty sure that most of you would have
been able to solve this problem now this
is a famous problem by Greeks and maker
gari
and was published in Journal of renewal
psychology at some point okay do you
know the answer to this problem
the answer is no and so those of you
congratulation who who could have solved
this problem and those of you could not
take this away there is no way that this
is possible this kind of arrangement is
possible and so they also found leak and
McGary also found that only fifty
percent of the people could solve the
problem and fifty percent could not in
if it is rushed through time but given
enough time most people were able to
solve it the answer is no it cannot be
done and so this is basically the idea
of our problem so basically in terms of
reaction time that reaction time doesn't
say how problem is represented because I
really don't know how did you represent
this problem and so maybe you have seen
a problem like this before ensue come up
with an answer and the accuracy of it
also doesn't know how you solve this
problem because I don't know how did you
make the representations of it so
basically then what is the way in which
I can understand how a referral program
is represented or how what is the
process of representing a problem or how
did people solve a particular problem
and one important way in which we can do
this is something called the verbal
protocol so what is the verbal protocol
now in order to understand the process
of problem solving researchers made
extensive use of something called verbal
protocol if you remember structuralism
there was something called insight and
insight is much much a close brother to
Verburg protocol and inside studies what
was done is people were asked to do
certain kind of psychological tasks and
then they were are when they were doing
this task they were asked to basically
relate how the task was being done and
this this insight generation was
something like this purple protocol is a
similar procedure in which people are to
report on how they generated the
solution to a problem so which are
reports so basically whatever protocols
these are reports generated by problem
solvers and they think aloud during the
solo
process so as you're following the
process are solving a problem people are
made to go ahead and report loudly how
they're solving it for example the
problem of how do you act two plus two
right now how do you go about it what is
the way of addition and so what you
could do is first I'll think about to
then I think about something called
addition addition is basically this then
I take the other two I use the operator
addition I go ahead and add this now I
come up with an answer now I verify this
so this is basically how our protocol
really works it so all the steps that
you take in doing addition of two plus
two or any other problem solution what
you have to do is you have to tell in a
stepwise manner what is going on or what
is the process that you are using and so
this is what is work per protocol you
see a problem here
I see and so what is the problem here
there are several problems with this
kind of a protocol and the first problem
is that everyone doesn't have the verbal
ability required to affect accurately
what they are thinking it's very
difficult to verbalize what people are
thinking and so the I the problem here
is that the ability of people to
basically narrate what they're thinking
is a major concern here people are not
able to narrate what they're thinking
and so verbal protocols fail or the idea
of loudly speaking out thinking aloud
what they're doing fails because people
don't have the verbal ability they
cannot generate or they don't have the
right verbal device or right horrible
requirements and enough words to speak
out the problem the second problem is
there is no way to assess the accuracy
of what the verbal reported somebody
would may say something else and they
must be doing something else and so
there is no way to tell if people are
lying or cheating or deliberately run
deliberately in in deliberately if they
are coming up with problems or if they
are inputting the right technique of how
they're solving the problem and so
there's no way of accuracy testing and
the third is the very act of thinking
aloud it may interfere with or change
the way and not
solutionist on and so since I'm doing a
dual task right I am also going ahead
and loudly shadowing the process of
problem solution which is basically
loudly also speaking it back so it's a
dual task and so this dual task may in
the nature of the task itself the idea
that I have to use also verbal memory or
verbal information processing verbal
representations are basically repeat
this thing back may create problems
because what will happen is this idea of
verbally repeating it things back may
interfere with a very idea of the
solution with a very idea of how the
thought process of solution really works
and so these are the problem with the
verbal protocols of course so these are
the problems with the solution of
problem now another problem or another
way why problem solution cannot cannot
be packed on towards difficult to look
at how problems are solved is because
problems are of varied nature and so the
complexity of the problem solving
presents another challenge for
researchers the fact that there are
different kind of problems and there are
device set of circumstances and from
right from solving a math problem to
solve in the verbal problem to solving a
traffic problem to solving n different
problems and so with these such a
circumstances there are a number of
problems that may arise and so all these
problems may have different different
solutions and so that could be one of
the factor or determining factor why
problem solution or looking at problem
salvation could be a problem in itself
now man 1992 he distinguished five
different types of problem that can
arise and so we look into these problems
one by one and then we look into the act
of the problem itself the first kind of
problem that mark in 1992 defined is
called the transformational problem and
so what is the transformational problem
it's a problem in which the solver is
presented with the goal state and and he
knows the initial state and then what he
has to do is to find out appropriate
strategies to use those strategies and
reach the goal state so you'll know the
initial state you know the goal States
and you have to do something or use the
appropriate problem-solving technique
problem-solving state
and eventually reach the goal state so
these are transformational problem you
have to transform from in each state to
the goal State
using certain rules or certain by
navigating certain hindrances and I went
that the second fire type of problem are
called arrangement problems what are
these problems they these problems
present the user all with all the
necessary elements which are required
for solving the problem what is the role
of the receiver then the solver of the
problem he has to then arrange all these
elements together in a way that gives
the final solution so you know all the
you are given all the problems solution
elements or you are giving all the parts
of how to solve a particular problem the
only job of a person here is to
basically arranged them rearrange
everything so that the solution comes
out of it the third type of problem
which arise here or which which people
in always face or which might define in
his in his problem solving or types of
problem definition is called an
induction problem and what is the
induction problem involves giving the
solver a series of examples or instances
sopra is basically forming an analog in
solving problem by analog so induction
problem a number of instances or
exemplars are given to you and using
this you have to figure out the pattern
or rule that relates the instances
together so you have a number of example
number of instances are given to you and
you know you have to find the pattern
through which these instances are
connected and once you know these rules
one you once you form or I understand
this rule you will be able to find the
final solution so induction problem
certain things are given to you certain
kind of examples or instances are given
to you you have to find the rule of how
they are connected and this rule will
actually give you the final solution of
how the how to reach from the initial
state to the final state in deduction
problem what happens is certain premises
or conditions are presented to people
and they need to determine whether a
conclusion fits the premises so certain
kind of provides a certain kind of truth
statements are given to people
to start with and then what people need
to do is to they have the conclusion in
front of them and they have to look at
the fact that given the fact that the
premises are true the conclusion czar
also true so this kind of reduction
problem we'll see in the next section
which is called thinking and reasoning
so in terms of reasoning and the
judgment and decision-making the next
section that we're thinking will see
these kind of problems basically these
kind of deduction problems or this kind
of premise rigid problems are
syllogistic reasoning and the inductive
reasoning and so we'll look at that in
the next section but for now what
deduction problem does is some certain
number of truth value certain number of
crude treatments are given to you and
what people need to do is to find out
that given the fact that certain two
truth statements are out there whether
the conclusion fits these two treatments
or whether the conclusion fits the
premises in certain way and the last
kind of problem which are there are
called the divergent problem so what are
these problems they operate as you know
in a way then a solver here has to give
a number of solution whatever comes to
your mind a number of solution and so
that is how the problem solution really
works or this kind of problem really
works so divergent problems and those
problems there are a number of solution
exists and the solver can then give you
a number of solutions so let's look at
these problems one by one the first kind
of problem so five different problem the
first kind of problem that you want to
look at is arrangement problem look at
these words here can you rearrange the
letters to form an answer the answer
here is VI ki ng very good for those of
you who could answer it so this is an
arrangement problem everything is given
to you here what you need to do is
rearrange the letters so that you get
the answer not diverting problem as I
said it lets the solver give a number of
solution and so as you think the problem
here could be think as many used objects
so bricks could be used for meeting
someone it could be used for making a
house bricks can be used for as a weight
as a substitute for weight it could be
paperweight it could be used in selling
something as in terms of standard
weights are so many other things right
and so these are divergent problems this
is a deduction problem so certain
premises are there and these premises so
all professors are carrying people this
is the premise and this is true the
second premise are all carrying people
are good this is again a premise which
is true and so now you have to validate
this conclusion which is drawn from
these two premises the fact that would
be accept the statement that all
professors are good whether all
professors are good follow from these
two statements and these kind of
problems are called the deduction
problems right so certain premises are
given to you and a conclusion has to be
validated against the premise the fourth
kind of problem is called the
transformational problem and so what is
here
I mean transformation problem you have
the initial state and the goal state
known to you and you have to use a
particular strategy to arrive from the
initial state to the goal State and so
as you see this is called the Tower of
Hanoi problem and so you have to the
fact here the requirement here is to
move these three workers from position a
to position C so same arrangement here
the only thing is you can make you can
move or these circles one at a time so
one movement is allowed you can move
from here to here or here to here kind
of a thing right also the fact that a
smaller circle will never go beneath
down on or a smaller circle cannot be
beneath a larger circle so that is the
kind of thing so how do you arrange from
here to here and so you are know that
this is the initial state this is the
final state and so by moving one at a
time and this constraint using this
constraint that a smaller circle cannot
be banette or cannot be below a larger
circle you can solve this problem this
is called a transformational problem and
the last kind of problem is called the
induction problem and this is look and
look at the number in your sequence and
then come up with and solution so this I
will explain to you this is rather
interesting so take your time solve this
problem I will give you the solution to
this problem
let's wait for it and because I'll use
this problem as some other at some other
places also so can you find out a rule
through which these numbers are
connected there is a rule remember so if
you go about 5 minus 4 is 3 or 4 5 8
minus 5 is 3 5 minus 4 is 1 4 minus 1 is
3 you will never come to the solution
because there is a certain rule to it
I'll tell you the rule but with that
will happen as we progress into this
section so how do I solve a problem what
are the various approaches to solving a
problem the rest several approaches to
solving a problem for example the first
approach is behaviorism solving problem
and associative learning so two
approaches I will describe here one is
the guest art across the other is the
behavioral approach comes from the first
section itself
introduction to already psychology where
we saw what is behaviorism behaviorism
is basically understanding simulus
response relations so basically what we
haver is said is there is nothing called
the cognitive system there is nothing
called the human mind there is a
behavior there is a response and making
connection between these behavioral
response or behavior in response is what
behaviorism is all about so look at each
behavior look at each response find the
most optimal response the most optimal
response is the correct response to the
stimulus and this is associative running
associating a response to a stimulus so
behaviorism presents a solution to
problem solving or gives a way to solve
problem and so the people who started
explaining problem solving s as be
various as behaviorism where early
behavior is like ile Thorndyke and so
turned like 1800 he conducted his first
estimating study of problem solving
using cats so what he did was he was
looking at feline animals and so he took
this salon animal put it into some kind
of a box a capture box and the cats
doesn't like to be captivated into box
so what he did was he took this cat put
it into a box and enclosed the box
within the box was a lever the cat had
to realize to press this lever now look
at the the easiness of it
what cats do when they and when you
enclose it into some kind of a structure
or in some kind of a cage it tries to
scratch it and so this lever was placed
in such a way that it needs to be
scratched down or bend down from the
power and so the scratching ability
would give the cat the idea to scratch
this or bend this paw and so later
sooner or later the cat will realize
that if I scratch here so where the
liver is so this is my box and so the
cat is put here right and so here is the
lever the cat initially goes ahead and
scratches everywhere right but once it
scratches here there is a door which
opens and the cat can not escape out of
it
so the cat has to realize that this is
what and this is the solution to the
problem so Trond I was interested in
knowing whether the ability to solve the
confinement problem would appear
suddenly as an insight of gradually
through the process of trial and
learning so what he was want what he
wanted to see is that whether cat did
something for learning the solution that
I if I scratch the right button window
door will open and I will get out of it
or whether the cat sits and through
inside through some kind of magic or
through some kind of a internal problem
solution will the cat to be able to know
that I scratch this and so what they
found out then the cat learned by learn
the idea that if I press this button the
door will open I can move out of it
through something called trial and error
and what is trial and error what the cat
did was it's crashed everywhere and so
if it scratched a number of times slowly
slowly it realized and if I scratch at
this button what is going to happen is
the door is going to open and I'm going
to come back of it and so that is what
he realized now turn like describe the
learning process with which Islam
there's something called the law of
effect and so what is law of effect it
states that if a response leads to a
satisfying outcome the connection
between the response and the situation
will be strengthened but if it leads to
not satisfying outcome this is deleted
so scratching
while satisfying or scratching on levers
catching on things which was coming out
of the cage was a successful response
was the cat scratched on everything
which was protruding out of the cage but
then it started not scratching on
polished surfaces
right so this this this idea of
sketching on to those objects which are
protruding out or protruding in or which
was shiny in the intron dyes case lead
to the freedom of the cat that is this
Association increase in assertion with
this fact that I should scratch on those
objects which are shiny on those objects
which are illuminated in some way or
this look which looks like a leaver will
actually make me escape is what is
called the law effect and so what a lot
of effects is that the cats learn that
when I do a certain act and if I am
positively rewarded I'll do this if I'm
not personally rewarded those acts I
will not do I said this is what the
tonic box is all about and what you can
see here is the number of trials is the
cat took and the number of time required
to escape and as you see initially it is
very high so this is trial and error and
so as the cat kept on doing it later on
the time required was in terms of 100
seconds right in the by the 7th plus 17
trial the cat was as fast as you put
into it million hundred second it will
escape but initially it was requiring
600 seconds to find this idea and so if
you can see this is where the cat is
this is what the arrangement is all
about and here you see the latches and
so it needs to scratch we scratched on
the right surface with the door we open
and that's what it was it and so what we
every said is that the solution to
problem is always in terms of trial and
error in a position to the guest artist
which believed that by forming perfect
associations between responses and
similar says can a problem be solved so
problem solution is basically making up
new associations and rewarding those
associations which give us a reward or
learning those institutions which give
us a reward guest artists oppose this
view
they said that problem solving is
basically insight related process which
basically means that it is not the actor
doing something which solves a problem
problem solving happens because people
restructure representations people
restructure the problem in certain way
meaningful representations and these
restructuring of meaningful
representation is how the solution
generated so against all psychologists
they believe that mind has an inherent
tendency to organize incoming
information so what the mind could go
and we saw in Gestalt Theory what get
start is proposed is certain Gestalt is
wrong and what does this get yes tartre
really say it's say that the mind
organizes stuff we structures
information restructures mental
representations and this is this
restructuring which gives solutions
which make easy solutions right so what
the mind does is it always organizes and
restructures information right now
defining features of condition thus
rather the defining problem solution as
mindless playing out of associations
that gradually build up over time they
believe that it involves restructuring
or reorganizing the problem so they
believe that its solution to problem
doesn't come from time again and again
making associations mindless
associations between the fact that some
time I will get rewarded or at some
point of time I'll get rewarded or some
of my behavior will get rewarded they
said it is not the solution the solution
is the solution from power to problem
comes from the fact that when I look at
a problem and not only look at a problem
i restructure it in certain way I
rearrange the problem elements in
certain way
such so that the answer comes to it that
is water solution to our problem is all
about now a pioneer to the study a
pioneer to gestalt get started school
was well google collar and so what he
did was he found a popular way of
basically or he found a way to test this
idea that insight leads to problem
solution so basically for guests our
psychologists then problem solve a
solution involves a process of
restructuring where my problem elements
are suddenly recognized and seen in a
new way so what happens is they believe
that the elements of a problem the
problem itself is restructured into a
mind and it is it is kept on
restructuring till the point of time
that a solution suddenly appears to you
and this is called insight or in some
books it will be called as the
experience so this our experience leads
the so what happens is that problem
solution has a stage where people don't
do anything they just sit
passively and reorganize the problem or
rotate the problem in subtle way
mentally restructure the problem in
certain way till a solution happens so
against the fact that what behavior says
that problem solution is all about
making or doing acts and learning a
solution what they believe is it is
mental restructuring which leads to
reorganizing of information which leads
to problem solution so the sudden
successful restructuring of a problem
element is termed the inside and this is
the major focus of gestalt approach and
so how they tested it they kept certain
monkeys and with crates and then an
appealing item so this is what an
appealing item is here is the appealing
item here some banana were actually
taken in in they were held on to the
roof and certain crates were given to
these monkeys and they were made to say
what corner found out is that initially
the monkeys try to jump to the roof and
take the banana now that was not
happening because no matter how hard the
monkey jumped they were not able to
reach the roof so what did they do they
kept trying everything right initially
they kept trying everything and then
after a period of time this sat there
with the idea now the solution is right
there in front of it there are number of
crates which can be put over one and
another and a kind of a ladder can be
generated so what these monkeys did was
they sat there for a certain period of
time and then later on after a certain
period time has elapsed suddenly the
idea came to them or they developed this
idea by restructuring this problem and
so this thought the boxes in this way
and now it is like a ladder and so he
climbed on the ladder and takes the food
so this is this wait time is what is
called the insight or this wait time is
what leads to the insight and the
solution to the particular problem out
there now cognitive psychology could
also suggest orders autosuggest solution
to problems so for any psychology also
is a way of solving problem in what is
the suggestion here now just as computer
solvers computer solves a problem by
executing programs that use certain
information stored on to it humans also
solve problem by applying certain mental
process to representations so what does
computer to computer program takes in
information in certain way arranges this
in
in a certain way the the certain kind of
processing on manipulations and come up
with a solution similarly what earlier
cognitive psychologists like Neville he
suggested that humans also saw problem
in this way the problem solid solution
happens by applying certain processes
applying certain rules are applying
certain methodologies to already story
play representations so already stored
representations which are coming from
perception attention and so on and so
forth the basic processes these
representations are basically taken in
and certain processes are applied on to
it and these processes lead to least two
four if I'm finding the solution to a
problem so basically they gave these
cognitive early cognitive psychologists
gave the idea of something called the
general problem solvers so what is the
net problems or the general problem
solver is a conceptualization of the
computer program we saw the problem and
so what are the general problem solver
does it takes in a problem breaks us
into subproblems and then by solving
this sub problem one by one attains the
final goal state and so this is what the
general problems are where does and so
this is about naval also said son Alan
Simon in 1972 they originated the
conceptualization of problem solving as
a step-by-step process from an initial
to the goal State
so what I do here is if I have a bigger
problem if I have a problem of writing a
research paper what I do is I break it
into smaller problems smaller sub goals
right and so each sub goal I take the
initial problem divided into in certain
parts and then each part now has a goal
in a sub goal and then what I do is
start from the first part such initially
from the first sub part reach to the sub
goal then start to the second part
sample so writing a paper could be first
going to the library and sitting there
achieving that once I do that then
reading something in the library then
understanding something then finding a
new problem then reading a little bit of
what that problem then coming up with
the answer of what the problem is then
discussing that with certain professors
or looking at certain materials that and
finally writing the paper so the writing
the paper is now broken down into
several steps and similarly well this is
what Neverland Simon did they said that
larger problems can be broken down into
smaller smaller problems and
can be solved by step-by-step process
from the initial state to the final say
they did so within the framework of a
computer program which is called the
general problem solver or the GPS now
what is the GPS the GPS is basically a
model of human computer problem solving
sorry human problem solving now one that
can be applied to any problem so
basically it is equivalent to computer
problem solution so basically the GPS is
a model of human problem solving which
is basically made or which is basically
developed out of the computer problem
solving things
now this approach approach minimize the
distance between the initial state and
the goal state by breaking the problem
down into a series of sub goals so what
I do is if a bigger problem is there I
know the initial state I know the goal
state and I don't know how to solve it I
take the initial problem I break it into
its part as I said making the writing
paper problem into his part so first
I'll go to the library first and achieve
that thing so initial goal is starting
from here final goes in which in the
library once I reach the librarian see
so many people are not motivated so
first problem solved in terms of
motivation of writing it then I will
read some books the more I read books
the more ideas will develop and when
that happens when I have more a number
of ideas with me I will then consult
some professor or some kind of a TV
program or some kind of internet
websites where more information is given
from there I could write a problem so
basically this this whole writing a
paper problem is not broken down into
sub parts this is what it is said here
in the GPS also I minimize the distance
with from the goal - back to the initial
problem by creating sub problems or by
creating sub goals and it is easier for
a person to reach from reach the goal
through sub goals then to reach the goal
on its own now the sub goal analysis is
accomplished through the application of
something called operators so how do you
reach the sub goal though there are
certain operators now what is operator
is basically a fancy word which is out
there for problem solving
techniques so one subway technique is
going to let's say the library and that
there is one thing into it and then
there is reading a book so how do you
read a book there is a certain technique
of motivating yourself and then there is
another technique and so on and so forth
so basically these problem-solving
techniques taking a bigger problem and
solving it require several techniques a
bigger problem could be how to find out
how do people process first language
right so if people have dual language
proficiency let's say I am a proficiency
of English in Hindi now something is
spoken to me in English how do I respond
to this device take this thing take this
word in English and search for solution
to it in English or do I take the
problem the word which is being spoken
to me in English
translate back into Hindi search for the
solution in Hindi then come up with the
solution in English and then respond it
back
now this is the problem how do I break
it in a several problem first is a
behavioral part second is the cognitive
part the third is the mirror physics
part so first I do some behavioral
analysis to see how the solution is and
then another sub part is there so part
of it looking at behavior response so
kind of design problems in terms of
several problems could be developed in
which a certain kind of a sentence is
given to you an answer is looked into
into so several kind of things is then
we look at the speed and accuracy of how
you are doing it then we'll design a
cognitive experiment or maybe a brain
related experiment EEG ERP experiment
where we look at the time process or the
brain potential what happens in the
brain when you are solving this problem
and by combining these two things
together these two subproblems
I can finally say how do people think or
what is the way because the behavioral
will only give you the result what
happens in the brain you don't know so
you use brain imaging techniques to tell
you what happens in the brain when this
kind of problem dual language or single
language people solve a problem so
basically that is what it is and so
these using those two techniques is
called using the operators so these
techniques are applied at the micro
level to reduce the differences between
the current state and the goal state so
what could happen is since I have
created a bigger goal
I mean from starting from the initial
point to the final point is as the
bigger the problem says the bigger
problem so is I'd not divide the problem
space into subproblems space and so the
I can use operator s both at the level
of micro level which means navigating
from navigating within the subproblem in
the in the earlier case that i defined
so i can use certain operators or
certain so use certain techniques for
studying only the behavioral part of it
and the electrophysiological part of it
this is called the micro level analysis
and then to reduce the distance between
the initial in the goal State or I could
use a bigger bigger technique which is
techniques of summation of results right
reduction technique or some other
technique by you through which I can
take the two results that I have the
behavioral result and the
electrophysiological result match them
together and game of the final solution
so I can use operators both at the micro
level where each part of the problem how
each part of the problem is solved or
sub problem is solved and then use
techniques at the micro level of
integrating these results together to
give us the final solution of how do
people who have two language
proficiencies really think so GPS is a
notion of problem space which basically
refers to the problem solvers mental
representation of the initial state the
goal state and all possible intermediate
sub goal states and the operator that
can be applied to these so basically GPS
talks about initial state a goal state
and subproblems and certain operators
into it so look at this definition or
look at this picture this is how the
solution will really look at this is an
idea of a human GPS general problem
system so as you look into it this is
the problem solver
this is the noticing or review mechanism
external environment long-term memory
immediate problem space transfer goals
and constraints this whole thing is
called the GPS now how does it really
work this is my GPS system so this is my
initial state and then I have so many
inputs these are operators on to it this
is my goal state what I do is I break my
problem into several parts so this is
the behavioral part this is
electrophysiological part this is the
cellular biology part of all surrender
biological mechanism part where I look
at certain cells of how they respond to
certain neurotransmitters which will how
they will work and this may be another
imaging this so this is
electrophysiology and this is a brain
imaging and from all these I will
combine the results together to come up
with the solution of how people who are
two language proficient think or how do
they come up with solutions so basically
then this is what it is this is how the
idea offer general problem solver is
really so in this today's lecture what
we did was we talked about what is a
problem first of all definition of a
problem and we thought different
different or definition features out
there then we looked at a number of
problems a number of types of problems
which exist out there and we discussed
these types one by one and after that we
looked at certain approaches to
solutions of problems we look at the
gestalt approach the cognitive approach
as well as the behavioral approach and
we saw how these what these approaches
has to offer as solution the problem in
the upcoming lecture will look into how
a problem is actually solved and then we
look into something called creativity in
inside of how do they go with problem
solving thank you
[Music]
you